so here's the first story from the Daily
Mail coo fears as Wagner Army Marches On
Moscow to Target evil military Chiefs
Kremlin accuses a leader of mercenary
leader of mercenaries leader of
mercenaries of inciting Civil War puts
its troops on Capitol streets and vows
to smash armed Mutiny as State tv runs
emergency Bulletin this is crazy they
say there are fears of a coup in Russia
as military vehicles were seen in the
streets after the chief of the is it
Wagner group or is it Wagner group
Wagner I think that's that's actually
appropriate pronunciation they called
for an armed rebellion and direct
challenge to the Kremlin yevgeny Prego
gen tonight pregosian said his Force had
crossed into Russia as he called for the
ousting of Russia's defense minister and
vowed to punish military leaders whom he
accused of killing 2 000 of his Fighters
the Wagner Chief said we had cross-state
borders will destroy anything that gets
in the way we go all the way we got this
photo it's here photo here armed vehicle
armored vehicles were allegedly on the
streets of Moscow so the first thing I
got to say is um was that saying believe
half of what you uh what does it believe
half of what you see and none of what
you read or hear or whatever I know
something like that take it all the
grain of salt I don't know for sure but
I will say this when I first heard this
story I was like what did NATO offer him
double
like this is how it goes with pmc's he's
fighting in Ukraine they're getting
demolished and then he's like it's not
worth the money he's a he's a private
military contractor what does he care
and then NATO says what are they paying
you dude and he was like you know 50
million he's like okay we'll give you
200 and he was like okay sure that's all
it takes right money printing machine
goes Burr this is the danger of hiring
mercenaries to fight a war uh happened
to the Rome I don't know if this is
exactly what happened with the Romans
but they were having they were bringing
in Mercenaries from all over the world
to come and fight for the Romans because
the Roman citizens it got to a point
where they didn't want to fight anymore
and then uh that's the beginning of the
end because those people do not have any
allegiance to your country this is the
American Revolution they brought in the
British brought in German mercenary
Hessians yeah
those are the people who got routed by
uh when ju when when when when George
Washington I almost said Joe Biden my
God uh when George Washington crossed
the Delaware it was the Hessians who got
routed Christmas Eve yeah that the
famous painting right the most famous
painting of the Revolutionary War that's
who he was going to fight the Germans
actually yeah I mean there is obviously
value to having a um a more robust
fighting force including mercenaries but
if you're relying on Mercenaries you're
in a you're in a very precarious
position this is what I never understood
you see a movie where it's like someone
hires a hit man I'm like and they always
say like what are they paying you I'll
pay you double it's just like why would
why would not this doesn't be like well
okay sure are they going to turn me in
if I if I don't do this I don't think
they're going to you have a reputation
to protect you as a Hitman though but
this is something that we see there's a
great book called The Modern mercenary
and there's a phenomenon that they call
neo-medievalism because one of the
problems during the Middle Ages was that
people had an allegiance to their lord
their God and their King so whenever
there was like a you know a conflict
broke out that was between any of them
you had to pick your own uh you had to
pick which Master you would serve so you
know mercenaries have different
interests different loyalties and all
that so obviously we might be saying if
this is true that Neo medieval order
like establishing itself once again in
our modern society so they're you know
they're they that they obviously aren't
loyal to Russia no he he's he says uh
quote there are 25 000 of us and we are
going to figure out why chaos is
happening in the country promising to
tackle any checkpoints he said he I
asked that no one offer resistance is 25
000 really enough to do anything I I
mean if they're centralized just in
Moscow yes
like they could take some building or
something but I just want to point out
that we're no longer in the era of being
able to take over a country by occupying
a building and it's kind of crazy to
think that was the case at some point
like a bunch of dudes would run into a
building and they're like we're in
charge now and everyone will be like
well crap they're in charge now yeah I
worked in uh Pinochet did that I think
with uh what was I end it Salvador
Allende in in Chile there was 11's in
the 70s I think it's like they just went
in but once you get the leader that's
what he wants is he wants the defense
minister if this is real he doesn't care
about the building but you can get the
people if you get Putin then you get
Putin at gunpoint to tell the people I
concede I stepped down you know you get
the leader to do what you want them to
do I think well power is influence right
so symbols of power do matter so
occupying Moscow even though
strategically you're like you're right
like they could move to another city uh
you know the Russian government has
access to nuclear warheads you would
think this doesn't matter but
symbolically occupying Moscow is a huge
deal and if people believe that this
mercenary group has more powerful than
the defense minister guess what it's
more powerful than the defense minister
has anybody ever occupied Moscow
since the beginning since the Kiev the
the old kievan princes yeah I mean
original everyone right every Empire
died trying but like has anyone ever
group right like it like this is it the
U.S finally figured something out there
like hold on hold on we can't invade
let's pay someone else to do it there
you go oh the French occupied Moscow we
didn't just figure that out I think
America's been doing that for a Moscow
has been occupied six times in its
history by Foreign armies wow the Polish
in 1610 to
France when was France French occupation
1812 Napoleon made it to Moscow I didn't
know I didn't realize no I thought it
was crazy Napoleon the summit of the
French but then what did he tried he
tried going further he lost his army
they only occupied it for 36 Days the
city was devastated by fire this is all
from Wikipedia
um and I'm just kind of oh yeah it
wasn't like they destroyed everything
the Russians they're pulling could have
any supplies and then he got screwed
over in the winter and was like we're
dying Scorch Earth policy as you Retreat
you burn everything so that the enemy
doesn't have anything is that scorched
Earth I thought was when you destroy
everything so that they cannot raise a
defense like you destroy farmland and
kill civilians you can be right because
Sherman's March to the Sea I think was
the first modern example of scorched
Earth whereas he marched South he'd
start destroying farms and killing
civilians and just wiping them all out
you could be right the Romans did it to
Carthage but there there is some there
is a tactic where as you're being
occupied you destroy everything didn't
they do that with Richmond the South
they sacked Richmond to prevent the
union from being able to utilize it or
something like that I don't know that is
common it's a very common and when
you're desperate you to burn your uh
your defenses as you as you Retreat so
that the enemy's not able to occupy I
mean they're doing that in Ukraine who
do you think blew up that giant damn the
Nova Dam but it wasn't the Russians well
this is the funny thing like Nordstrom
for instance they're like Russia blew up
its own Pipeline and you're like
nah bro
like nah that's no Ukraine blew up the
dam is is this this is not definitive
though this is like you've got warring
propaganda so the New York Times uh did
a report on how Ukraine has sort of
poison pills all throughout the country
to blow up their own infrastructure in
the Washington Post said that they did a
test strike on the dam uh earlier in the
year like they did an operation to test
so you can just connect the dots there
yeah and I think the blowing of the dam
flooded or has potential to flood Crimea
the Crimean that's right it really hurts
the Russians to blow up the dam and it's
a very bad thing who benefits from this
so the pipeline that was destroyed is
the one that allows them to transport
oil in gas without going through Ukraine
so obviously that gives them the ability
to cut off the ukrainians from energy so
that would be a prime target for the
ukrainians to destroy or their allies
being the United States or whoever
like it wouldn't make sense for Russia
to cut off their own strategy this is a
it's a good kind and they're and they're
sorry they're winning too aren't they
Panda it's tough to tell but here's what
I noticed they've been saying uh Western
forces Western media's been saying
Russia has been losing the whole time
and then I keep looking at these maps of
territory and Russia's expanding its
control over the Don bass and I'm like
I'm confused like now they're saying
that this region where the dam is is
controlled by Russia and I'm like wow
Russia controls how much I thought they
were losing that they were getting
pushed back I thought that was a big
offensive that pushed back into Russia
but Russia controls all this land I was
like it doesn't sound like they're
losing I mean I'm not here to say
they're winning or anything but it
doesn't sound like they're losing dude I
don't know though I don't know there's a
lot of propaganda this will be if this
truly is that the Russians accidentally
shelled 2 000 of their own mercenaries
and now the mercenaries turn on them
that will be remembered for
tens of thousands of years if we have
history for that if we can maintain it
it'll be remembered as one of the
largest military blunders ever in the
history of humankind I just don't
believe it yeah it's it's a it's a for
that convenient piece of propaganda
exactly and it's it's much simpler that
a multi-billionaire went to the Wagner
group and said we will give you 100
billion dollars to your company you will
be the preeminent in in the you know
Eastern Hemisphere military contractor
for all of our work forever you will
want for nothing side with us
it's a simple question you go to the guy
and you say do you think Russia's going
to win and he's going to be like
is it really worth how much money he's
paying you well this is what we do it's
like we'll pay you 10 times as much and
you'll win and he goes deal
that simple we did just have a what 6.2
billion dollar accounting error
no joke maybe yeah whoops and now the
guys got six billion dollars probably
alike dude he made he makes a video
claiming whatever he wants how much
money they have to give him to make it
happen probably not a lot he's a private
military contract he runs a business if
he he works with Russia and Russia ends
up succeeding or pushing in this fight
his only custom his only customer is
going to be Russia he's looking right
now they're probably telling him listen
once this whole thing dies down you've
got potential conflict in the country a
country B country C country D you've got
China Taiwan you've got you know uh the
entire continent of Africa and South
America we can hire you for all of these
things but if you operate with Russia
that's the only customer you will ever
have yes and and what are you gonna buy
after they may have even gone on said
after we we flatten Russia where will
you live will you with with all of the
great money they paid you will you buy a
building in Siberia perhaps or how about
this we give you a billion dollars you
turn out of Russia and you can buy
property anywhere in the world
heck we'll give you an island
not a hard deal that's the danger of
using mercenaries there's an island
called little Saint James that is
recently unoccupied and it has a special
temple on it that's brand nearly brand
new lightly used special blue and white
temple those are your colors right
Wagner blue and white you'll love this
place
it's got a real Eastern European Flair
to it yeah this is the pro I mean yeah I
didn't think you might I mean obviously
I think you might be right here I'm
furiously searching for the map the
wartime map because actually Russia's
gained a enormous amount of territory of
Ukraine's and this Ukrainian offensive
that they've been talking about has done
nothing it's actually been an absolute
total failure you don't hear about it
because we're propagandized as much as
anyone else in the world but the the the
Ukrainian spring offensive has been
there has been very very bad and as you
can see where all the money is gone it's
now in flaming tanks and uh personal
carriers all throughout the Eastern
front of Ukraine and the most effective
group if you go through on the YouTube
and some of the YouTube channels and
you're able to do the Google translate
thing and you're able to listen to these
Ukrainian generals talk the people
they're actually scared about is the
Wagner group that's that's the people
they talk about they say the Russian
army is is ineffective it's this Wagner
group these guys are actual operators
they are sophisticated they're smart and
they're all they also have a wartime
experience so they're not rattled at all
because Russia's putting a lot of young
guys on the front lines and so if you go
through and you watch some of these
YouTube some of the key of post is the
one that I watch right because they do
they have these Insight in these
interviews with these these Ukrainian
generals and they talk about how uh
worried they are about the Wagner group
and how a skilled of an operation that
is
and so this is clearly something that is
if they if you were to take them off the
board off the chessboard uh well hot
damn I mean this would be a big thing
obviously for Ukraine I always thought
about mercenaries and what a what a a
hard life that is because the the people
that hire you to fight want you to die
on the battle that they win they want
you to win the battle but die so they
don't have to pay you so it's like they
don't have Russia doesn't care about
these people like the Russians they want
to win and they would rather not pay
them to be honest uh obviously they
liked loyalty over non-loyalty but
mercenaries know that and if you kill
their men man they they are not gonna
wait
we don't do very well with taking care
of the people who fight our our Wars
either though so it's not like that's uh
I mean I see what you're saying but in
general I don't really think that uh in
most cases many of the people that come
back from war are really taken care of
in any way shape or form so but veterans
make up 11 of all the homeless
population in America veterans make up
11 large portion of the suicide our
veterans yeah we do use mercenaries in
part because the soldier death numbers
always gets reported because the
American people care about soldiers
dying overseas and when it's Personnel
even though they're former soldiers that
served our country that went into these
mercenary groups it's not as like scary
of a number so like there is some more
concern in the United States for at
least the death toll especially overseas
and we started like upping our use of
private military after we started
withdrawing troops at a certain point
right back in like 2013 or something
like that in Afghanistan yeah
so just just to clarify because people
are pointing out scorched Earth two two
super chats saying that it's when people
are defense when a defending Army
destroys everything another person
responded it's actually both uh but most
but most famously associated with
offending armies destroying anything of
use to the the place they're occupying
but there are several circumstances in
which people in their own countries
destroyed everything as they were
fleeing but scorched Earth
uh the specific examples when you pull
up the Sherman's March to the Seas like
the most notable modern example yeah and
that was when he was like destroy the
Farms destroy the railroads anything
they can use the the purpose was to
destroy their will to fight so just to
completely demoralize I thought about
the Third Reich did this in Russia like
when they they were on the edge of
Moscow as far as the Third Reich got in
Russia and they were as close as any
modern Army's been to to conquering
Moscow and man they burned the they they
burned everything on their way back
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time